explain Russia and Ukraine war in the
style of Tim Dillon let's see what it
says they're saying that the chat bot is
going to replace a lot of white-collar
workers you know oh my God
listen folks the Russian Ukraine war is
a real mess it's like a big old game of
chess but instead of Pawns it's people
getting killed it started in 2014 when
Putin decided to flex his muscles and
Annex Crimea from Ukraine that's like if
Canada decided to take Maine it's not
cool now the International Community
they're trying to do something about it
but it's like trying to put out a fire
with a squirt gun see thank God this
thing's not as good as me yet but it's
scarily close this is scarily close
bottom line folks this conflict is a
real mess it's a shame that it's come to
this and Putin well he's just playing
his own game and he doesn't care who
gets hurt in the process it's not quite
me yet but it's terrifying that is
terrifying how close that is